it's great to be joined today by Billy
Delancey who's the co-founder and CEO of
lobbyists for good which is a
crowdfunding platform that enables
everyday people to hire professional
lobbyists so Billy that this is sort of
there's this debate in politics about
inside outside strategies do you work
within a system to your advantage or do
you try to change the system if you
believe that the system is fundamentally
broken corrupt or otherwise not not
working properly when it comes to
lobbying this is I think you would agree
an extraordinarily corrosive element of
American politics but it is here and it
appears to be here to stay is your
argument on that basis let's see if we
can use it to do some good that's
exactly at davidon thanks for having me
on the program lobbying isn't going to
go away even if we were to pass a law
that banned lobbying having people not
allowed to lobby that it would be
guaranteed to be thrown out because of
the First Amendment there's a line that
says that everybody has the right to
petition the government for redress of
grievances so that's exactly right wait
how you said it why don't we use the
tools available to change the system and
get everyday people to have a stronger
voice in government how does the
platform work is it sort of like a
Kickstarter for lobbying that's exactly
what it is and we actually use that
description when when describing it to
people individuals everyday American
citizens or green card holders can go on
to our platform and submit ideas or
campaigns around issues that they care
about and if the individual campaign
raises five thousand dollars within a
hundred days we will go ahead and find a
lobbyist here in DC to advocate for
their cause on Capitol Hill
now how much professional lobbying this
five grand get you because it feels like
it might get you you know a paragraph
email or something like that
yeah not much the reason we have the
$5,000 and most people that's the first
thing they point out too we had we had a
haier originally but because we're a new
organization because we don't have a
large email list we wanted the barrier
of entry to be a little bit lower so we
have $5,000 right now about 40 hours of
lobbying and the thing is that we're
gonna do a lot of the backend research
so when you come up when you start a
lobbying campaign and there's a lot of
work around strategy researching the
issue identifying targets on the hill
we're gonna do a lot of that so that the
people that we hire will be able to go
directly to the hill and use that that
time to meet one-on-one with legislators
and their staff so let's think through
sort of in total when we think about the
amount of money that might be raised on
your platform for individual lobbying
efforts hypothetically if all of that
money were pooled together and used to
try to change the system of lobbying and
campaign finance that we have might it
have a bigger impact it's an interesting
question but I think we might be
thinking a little bit too big I started
the platform to help people there's a
woman who started a campaign who's a
female veteran and there's a bill in in
Congress that would help force the VA to
look after female veterans because it's
just when such a male-dominated system
so that type of effort could pass a bill
like that 5,000 10,000 because it has
bipartisan support and just needs a push
to the end we lobby for the Institute of
Peace which is an organization that
tries to mitigate unless environment
conflicts are in the world and we spent
about 40 hours and we were able to
increase their budget by three million
dollars so do I think that this is a
platform that's going to change our
democracy and fix every problem that we
have I don't know I hope it's a useful
tool but it's one of many many things
that need to happen but I think that
we're gonna be very successful by
helping these these issues and these
these people who don't know where to
even begin or who call their legislator
convince their legislator but need to
reach all
34 other senators in Congress of all I
should say 532 if they get there both
senators in the Congress so we're trying
to focus more on just getting that
individual person a stronger voice
whether or not we can be used as a tool
to fix all the ills American democracy
I'm not convinced yet but I hope that we
can be part of the solution can you talk
a little bit about how the lobbying
process works I mean I think people
generally have an understanding that for
example like a large corporate Lobby
gets like the National the NCTA which
lobbies on the behalf of telecom and
cable providers those cable providers
and big companies give NCTA a bunch of
money and then NCTA
goes and does what like what is the
actual nuts and bolts of the lobbying
process a lot of it's just building
relationships and and using those
relationships to get 30 minutes of the
staffers time
that's an interesting example of a
telecom because they have hundreds and
hundreds of lobbyists working for them
every day and most of those lobbyists
are connected whether they worked on the
hill before or whether or not they're
former members of Congress themselves
but an organization like that uses those
relationships and uses the money that
they give to political candidates to get
the access to get that staffers 20
minutes at the right time when the bill
that they're working on is at the right
moment when they need a favor or they
need an action on it and it really is
about that relationship building I'll
give a story about our experience in
lobbying we identified the Institute of
Peace as an organization that really was
important and was completely ignored by
both Democrats and Republicans and so
what we did is we hired a lobbyist a
Republican who had worked with a lot of
people in foreign aid and foreign
affairs and all we did and we didn't
give a dime to any political candidates
we didn't you know walk into the
Congress with a bag of money we emailed
him and he used a lot of his personal
connections
when he worked on the hill and we just
asked for 30 minutes of people's time
and we went in and we went in with a
good argument and we said you know this
is why the Institute of Peace needs to
be funded at a higher level the war in
Iraq is winding down and when it does
there gonna be a lot of conflicts
between the groups that came together to
fight Isis or ISIL and we need somebody
to be there to talk to those groups and
have a peace mediation conflict
resolution and it worked and we were
able to get three million dollars pretty
much on a three thousand dollar effort
so that they could increase the programs
that they were doing in Iraq and
Afghanistan so to answer your question
if sorry if I was long-winded
it's about accessing the people who need
to you need to reach and it's about
going in with a good argument and then
having an appropriate follow-up for when
the bill that you're concerned about is
in the legislative process to reach out
to those people and say listen this is
how I want you to vote this is I need
you to co-sponsor and kind of that's how
you can work the system so 3,000 and
lobbying spend for three million in
funds seems like is that a tenth out
10,000 percent return I'm not sure I
didn't exactly run the numbers but it
seems like it might be a 10,000 percent
return do you have data about what the
return is on lobbying investment either
across the entire lobbying space within
particular industries or you know any
data you might have about that it's all
it's not our data but it's the sunlight
foundation did a study and they found
and I'll give three examples when oil
companies lobbied for a subsidy that
would benefit them they found a 5,000
percent return on their investment when
corporations banded together and lobbied
for a tax holiday of corporate tax
holiday and I think the year was 2003
2004 they found a twenty two thousand
percent return on their investment and
when pharmaceutical companies lobbied
for the provision in Medicare where they
couldn't compete the drug prices and I'm
a little iffy on exactly what they
before but it was about you know
competing for drug prices 76,000 percent
return on their investment and so we're
hoping that we can have that kind of are
aligned for the people and I'll just
really quick I used to work in foreign
affairs foreign aid and we lobbied for
an increased budget in foreign aid and
you know I gave $20 to Save the Children
a wonderful organization that does a lot
of good work around the world and here
in the US and then when we lobbied for
them we were able to get bumps of two
million four million so individuals can
do a great service by donating but a lot
of the change really does come from
government whether it's a policy whether
it's funding the return on investment of
the lobbying a lobbyist is staggering
how does your organization determine
what a good project is in other words
people could disagree about what
priorities should be or about what
really deserves attention or lobbying
funds spent on it so what what sort of
the infrastructure to determine what is
good enough well that's a great question
and in one way we struggled with we
don't want to drive policy we want to be
a tool a resource to connect people
outside of the Beltway to people who
have influence in government so that
they can have a stronger voice and so
what we decided to do is just have a set
of founding principles that every
lobbying campaign must meet and if it
meets those founding principles we will
host it on a platform even if it's
something that we don't necessarily
support a hundred percent but everything
within those founding principles will
will be hosted on a platform and it's
pretty simple it's it has to be for the
common good and that means that it can't
benefit an industry it can't benefit a
group of people specifically ask the
benefit everybody as a whole it has to
be driven by the second one is it has to
be driven by the people so a CEO of a
telecom communications can't submit a
campaign to our platform and an advocate
for defeating the neutrality so it has
to be
driven the other things that are
required number three is that it has to
be it have a chance of bipartisanship so
anything super far last super far-right
where no buddy on the other party is
gonna we call it dead on arrival in the
hill
we won't host campaigns like that and
that kind of weeds out any of these
extreme policies extreme politics the ID
the ideological extremes that could be
on our platform so we have that as a
protector and then the other thing the
last thing is that it needs to be
underrepresented there's a lot of good
nonprofits out there there's a lot of
great organizations that lobby for some
great causes and if their money is if
people's money is gonna be better
donated to that organization will
instruct the person to fundraise for
that organization but what we found is
even if there is a great nonprofit
that's has you know three four five
lobbyists they're going against 50 60 70
better paid lobbyists from the corporate
or from the special interest group that
opposes so we haven't used that
underrepresented one yet but we do feel
that we want to be kind of the voice for
the voiceless so those were in super
super interesting and I encourage people
to check out the lobbyists for good
website we've been speaking with Billy
Delancey who's the co-founder and CEO of
lobbyists for good a Billy will be
following it and I look forward to
seeing the success of future campaigns
I appreciate it David thanks so much for
having me on